encuentra la suma 15 menos 46 más 29 y
bueno primero vamos a concentrarnos en
sumar 15 con menos 46
muy bien después nos preocuparemos del
29 pero por ahora vamos a hacer
15 15 más menos 46 déjenme lo hago en
otro color
15 más menos 46
y bueno déjenme dibujo aquí una línea
numérica una recta numérica para poder
visualizar qué es lo que está pasando
así que ahí tengo mi recta numérica y
estamos empezando en el 15 voy a poner
el 0 por aquí y comenzamos en el 15 el
15 digamos que está por ahí y entonces
entonces esta flecha de aquí llega justo
al 15 y como el 15 tiene el valor
absoluto 15 esta flecha amarilla tiene
longitud 15 ahora estamos sumando menos
46 y esto es exactamente lo mismo que
decir 15 menos 46 así que nos vamos a
mover 46 unidades a la izquierda eso es
lo que me dice el signo negativo me dice
que me tengo que mover a la izquierda
así que empezando en 15 me muevo 46
unidades
a la izquierda entonces la longitud de
esta flecha la longitud de esta fecha
aquí es 46 nos estamos moviendo a la
izquierda así que esto es al menos 46
que le estamos sumando al 15 y entonces
acá vamos en algún punto por aquí y este
punto claramente está a la izquierda de
0 está más 15 unidades a la derecha y
luego nos movimos 46 unidades a la
izquierda
y de hecho podemos encontrar el valor
absoluto de este número azul
originalmente teníamos esta flecha
amarilla de longitud 15 y esta flecha
naranja de longitud 46 así que quiero
averiguar quién encontrar la longitud de
esta flecha azul y bien pues cómo
podríamos encontrar su longitud pues yo
conozco la longitud de la flecha naranja
y de la flecha amarilla pues la flecha
azul simplemente es la diferencia entre
la flecha naranja
y la flecha amarilla
ok entonces así que esto es 46 menos 15
65 es 14 13 así que la longitud de esta
fecha va a ser 31 iba a ser 31 a la
izquierda del 0 así que esto es menos 31
muy bien entonces yo sé que esta parte
de aquí es menos 31 ya eso ahora le voy
a sumar el 29 que tengo por acá de jaén
me gusta otro color así que ahora
empezamos en menos 31 y nos vamos a
mover 29 unidades a la derecha porque
estamos sumando un número positivo así
que terminamos justo por aquí digamos
que esta flecha
esta flecha déjenme la vuelvo a dibujar
es más déjenme la dibujo que esta flecha
esta flecha morada va a tener longitud
29 y va hacia la derecha muy bien
entonces tengo esta flecha morada de
longitud 29 pues esto nos va a dejar en
dónde
en donde nos va a dejar pues digamos que
acabamos en este punto y como encuentro
ese número pues de nuevo vamos a
visualizarlo y eventualmente ya no
tendrán que dibujar estas rectas
numéricas entonces bien empezamos en -31
y le sumamos 29 así que nos estamos
moviendo a la derecha 29 unidades pero
como 29 es más chico que 31 todavía no
alcanzamos el 0 todavía tenemos un
número negativo y como lo puede
encontrar esta parte cita blanca pues de
nuevo la parte blanca más este 29 debe
dar 31 si pensamos sólo en valor
absoluto si nos olvidamos de los signos
y sólo consideramos la longitud de las
flechas o dicho de otro modo 31-29 nos
dará la longitud de esta parte blanca y
representa un número negativo porque en
la suma el número negativo tiene un
valor absoluto más grande que el número
positivo así que cuantos 31 menos 29
pues claramente esto es 2 no podíamos
prestar un 1
esto convierte en 211 menos 9 todos así
que esto tiene longitud 2 entonces menos
31 más 29 todavía sigue siendo un número
negativo no nos hemos movido lo
suficiente a la derecha entonces esto es
un -2 así que el valor absoluto de la
parte blanca es dos porque 2 más 29 es
31 y como vimos en realidad es un número
negativo y bien déjenme lo escribo todo
en nuestra respuesta a toda la suma es
menos